- Elon Musk owns Twitter,
and now Twitter is owning Elon Musk.
His first few weeks of
ownership have been interesting.
And wouldn't you know it when
you light 44 billion dollars
on fire for the lulls?
You're bound to run
into some legal headaches.
Now things are changing so fast
that by the time you watch this video
the platform could be gone.
It could be borrowed by Mark Zuckerberg.
It could be turned into an NFT, I guess
or doing business as usual, who knows?
But here's a quick rundown
of everything that Musk
has accomplished so far.
He fired half of Twitter's total workforce
and then scrambled to hire
some of them back after stating
that Twitter should be
politically neutral.
He endorsed the Republican Party
before the midterms, I bet
that quickly backfired.
He announced a new rule
requiring users engage
in parody to include parody in their bio.
And then when that
didn't work to include it
in their Twitter name, which is exactly
the same thing that the
Onion just demolished
as being contradictory to
the entire point of parody.
He promised advertisers that
Twitter would not become a free
for all hell scape and then loosened up
on content moderation, resulting
in a measurable increase
in people being awful racist
or homophobic and leading
to a whole bunch of advertisers
leaving the platform
at least temporarily. He
got rid of the Blue Check
verification system and
replaced it with an $8 a month
subscription service that
didn't verify user identity
allowing people to impersonate
brands and celebrities.
That's how we got a seemingly verified
George W. Bush tweeting,
"I miss killing Iraqis."
And a seemingly verified
Rudy Giuliani saying, "Nancy Pelosi
and I do not agree on many
things, but them thangs
thanging I'll tell you what."
(audience applauding)
Now, all this has been great
fun to observe, but now
that Twitter is a raging dumpster
fire, Musk has to contend
with some serious legal issues
including how he was forced to buy Twitter
in the first place, the FTC
gauntlet that is facing Twitter
and then there's the
wrongful termination suits
and possible bankruptcy.
It's a real Sue's sue.
Now, when we last visited
Elon Musk and Twitter,
Musk was arguing that
Twitter had misled him
about the number of bots on Twitter
and that it's now former
leadership had fired employees
without his consent.
So he was calling off the deal.
At the time
I speculated that it would
be tough for him to get
out of that deal to buy the company,
take it from Devon from the past.
Delaware courts have been known to
order specific performance
in just such a situation
as this.
Twitter sued Musk
for a specific performance in
the Delaware Chancery Court.
They wanted to force
him to purchase Twitter
at the agreed upon price.
The Chancery Court has jurisdiction to
hear all matters related
to equity, which means
that it had the power to compel him to go
through with a purchase.
Musk wanted a discovery
process that would take months
if not years to complete.
But in July, the court ruled that Musk
and Twitter needed to be
ready for trial by October.
That's an insanely fast
timeline for a major trial
but such is life in the
Delaware Transfer Court.
They do not mess around presumably feeling
that he did not have enough
time to make a decent case
or just saw the writing on the wall.
Musk went through with the
purchase and bought the company
at the original sales
price of 44 billion dollars
on October 28th.
So in the end, it was
much a sue about nothing.
Now, Musk fans, what are they?
Muskavites, I guess rejoiced
because he promised them
that he would be a
champion of free speech.
Musk had assured us that
Twitter is the new town square
and everyone has a First Amendment right
to more or less say whatever
they want on the platform.
Though he did begin to
backtrack almost immediately
as Musk said, by free speech
I simply mean that which matches the law.
I'm against censorship that
goes far beyond the law.
Though Musk's actions
didn't match his words almost immediately.
When Twitter users
started making fun of him
he suspended their accounts.
Kathy Griffin probably has an entire mug
of billionaire tears by now.
And sure Musk has a legal right to
be a delicate sensitive boy.
It just doesn't match
his particular rhetoric.
The First Amendment prohibits
the United States government
from censoring speech,
but private companies
or private individuals can
censor speech if they want to.
If Musk wants to shut down
speech from progressives
and liberals and promote
speech from conservative voices
he has a right to do that or vice versa.
He can ban people who hurt his feelings
and he can turn Twitter into a hell scape
of bullying and racism
if he wants to do that.
That much is obvious.
However, that choice is
not without consequences.
And Musk got a lesson in the
free market almost immediately.
At least 50% of Twitter's
advertisers have fled the platform
since Musk took over.
And just
as Musk has a right to run
Twitter the way that he wants
more or less
advertisers are free to not
advertise on the platform.
That's the free market at work there.
Now the issue here is that Musk claims to
be a free speech absolutist.
He apparently believes
not just in free speech
in the sense that the
government can't censor people
but also consequence free speech
and that's just not how things work.
And we know this in particular
because Elon Musk keeps
firing Twitter employees who
either make fun of Elon
or say things that Elon
doesn't agree with.
Now he can do that subject
to some limitations we'll talk about later
but we can also make fun
of him for his free speech hypocrisy.
Now, at the same time
Musk temporarily ditched a verification
in favor of a pay per blue policy
and one of the consequences
from that was that
an Eli Lilly impersonator
promised to make insulin free.
And some have speculated this might have
cost the company around 15
billion dollars in market share.
Though I'm skeptical
of the causation there.
But still, this deters companies
from even wanting to engage
on Twitter, let alone pay the
company to run advertisements.
Now, Musk says he's
going to create a content
moderation council to
review suspended accounts
but he also has fired
the entire Twitter safety
and security team
so he'll have to build
that council from scratch.
Now, Musk also fired 80%
of Twitter's contractors around the world
which maintain the core
infrastructure services
that keep the site up and running.
That's probably not important.
And as much as Musk would
like to believe that
the advertiser problem is
caused by activist woke brands
it might have just as much
to do with instability
and potentially a
deteriorating site experience
which might only get worse.
And a day after the
mass termination Musk confirmed
the dumpster fire tweeting,
"By the way, I'd like to apologize
for Twitter being super slow
in many countries, app is doing more
than 1000 poorly bashed RPCs just
to render a home timeline."
And independent reports also state
that Twitter's code-based suffers
from sinus sotal delineation,
which could be fixed
with the proper flex
capacitors and proton packs.
Now, it's been fun
watching Elon just tweet
through all of this, but
in all the excitement
he seems to have overlooked
a big legal issue
which is Twitter's consent decree
with the Federal Trade Commission.
Twitter's chief Privacy Officer,
chief Compliance Officer
and Chief Information Security
Officer abruptly quit shortly
after Elon rolled out new product features
without the security reviews
that the FTC required
in its decree with the company,
the employees went on Slack
and warned their colleagues
that Musk's new plans
are extremely dangerous for our users.
Also, given the FTC can
and will find Twitter
billions of dollars pursuing
to the FTC consent order
extremely detrimental
to Twitter's longevity as a platform.
And the employees then posted
a link to Whistleblower Aid
a nonprofit law firm that helps
employees report corporate
or government wrongdoing.
Now, what caused Musk's privacy
and security officers to
issue such a dire warning?
Well, it started with a consent decree
and the government agency responsible
for consumer protection, the
Federal Trade Commission.
It all goes back to
2009 when Twitter's lack
security processes allowed hackers to
obtain unauthorized
administrative control of Twitter
including both access
to non-public user information
and private tweets.
Hackers were also able to send
out phony tweets from any account.
In 2010 the FTC sued Twitter
for misleading consumers
about the privacy of
their personal information
and for failing to protect
user phone numbers.
In 2011, Twitter entered into
a consent decree with the FTC.
A consent decree is an
agreement that settles a dispute
without the defendant
admitting guilt or liability.
The consent decree has to be approved
by a judge making it
enforceable by the court.
So the Twitter consent
decree barred the company
from making misleading statements
about the extent to which it
protects the security, privacy
and confidentiality of
non-public consumer information.
And under the terms of the
decree, Twitter agreed to
maintain a comprehensive
information security
program and allow an
independent auditor to
assess its programs every other year
for the first 10 years after the decree.
In May of 2022, just
as Musk was purchasing
Twitter, the FTC accused
the company violating the
original consent decree.
According to the FTC complaint, more
than 140 million Twitter
users provided email addresses
or telephone numbers to Twitter based
on Twitter's deceptive statements
that their information would be used
for specific purposes
related to account security.
In reality, Twitter is accused
of using the personal data to
target users with advertising.
Twitter settled this
claim paid 140 million
in fines and entered into
a new consent decree.
The terms of the updated
consent decree require
significantly more stringent
monitoring of Twitter's privacy
and security claims, which
are audited by a third party.
Twitter agreed to conduct
a privacy assessment
of any new products it launches
and provide the assessment to the FTC.
Rihanna
who used to be Twitter's outside counsel
summarized Twitter's
obligations like this quote,
"If Twitter so much as sneezes,
it has to do with privacy
review beforehand."
Now, we don't know if and
to what extent Twitter is
violating the FTC consent
decree, but we do know
that Elon Musk has a
history of not particularly
carrying what government
agencies tell him to do.
So it's not clear if Twitter's new
or old staff are in compliance
with the consent decree
but more on that will
probably come out eventually.
And while all of this is going on
Elon Musk put the stand on Wednesday
in the shareholder's derivative suit that
seeks to nullify the 2018
pay package that he received
as Tesla's CEO.
Under the terms of that deal
Musk's compensation would be divided
into 12 batches of stock
that would be dispersed
as Musk hit predetermined
milestones, which he did.
As a result, Musk received
over 50 billion dollars
in Tesla's stock.
Now, these are difficult cases to win.
Generally courts don't like to
review the business decisions
of a company.
This class action argues
that Tesla's board
of directors were unduly
influenced by Musk
and failed to disclose crucial information
about the deal to the shareholders
who approved the deal.
But Musk had to testify in that case.
And because he's a
legal genius, he implied
that he doesn't need to
comply with consent decrees
in reference to an SEC consent
decree, Musk apparently
said, "The consent decree
was made under duress."
An agreement made under duress
is not valid as a foundation
of law, to which he was asked,
"Are you trained as a lawyer?"
To which he replied,
"I have some familiarity
with the legal system.
If you're in enough lawsuits
you pick up a few things along the way."
The thing is, the FTC doesn't mess around.
Many have argued that the
SEC doesn't have enough teeth
but the FTC sometimes in conjunction
with the DOJ can make things hurt not only
with much bigger fines,
but sometimes jail.
Just ask Uber's former
chief security officer
who was recently convicted
on federal charges
for obstruction against the
FTC or ask Facebook who got hit
with a 5 billion dollar
fine for violating a
consent decree related
to Cambridge Analytica.
And following on the heels
of these mass firings
Elon apparently sent
another late night email
in which he told Twitter
that they needed to
be more hardcore, that
they needed to respond,
they were willing to put
in grueling hours or not
and they had until 5:00 PM to respond
or they would be fired with
three months of severance.
Now, given the added debt that Musk added
to Twitter, Musk claims
that he needs to make
things profitable Twitter
which is why he laid off
half of Twitter's staff.
And meanwhile, allegedly a lawyer
on Twitter's privacy team has apparently
overheard Musk's lawyer say
that, "Elon is willing to take
on a huge amount of risk in retaliation
to this company and users
because Elon puts rockets
into space and he's
not afraid of the FTC."
And also the whistle
blowing lawyer also said
that Twitter engineers would
have to take on the burden
of personally certifying that
the products they designed
for Twitter comply with
the consent decree.
Now, this is obviously hearsay,
but it may also be true
because there haven't exactly
been some vociferous denials
of it either.
Now, if true, then Twitter is requiring
the engineers to take
on all the risk, but the
consent decree does not
allow individual employees
to certify Twitter's privacy
and security systems.
The FTC agreement requires Twitter to
submit any significant
change in operations
to an outside auditor before
it can be implemented.
And according to the Washington Post
the FTC expects Twitter to
submit a new audit in January.
The sources said that
before Musk even took over,
the company was already
scrambling to hire enough
people to meet that deadline.
And the FTC issued a statement,
"When you're tracking recent developments
of Twitter with deep
concern, no CEO or companies
above the law and companies
must follow our consent decrees.
Our revised consent order
gives us new tools to
ensure compliance and we
are prepared to use them."
And that takes us to labor
and employment law because
there have been lots
of changes for Twitter employees.
Musk has fired almost
4,000 Twitter workers.
And although Musk has the
right to fire employees
this right is not unlimited.
Twitter still has to follow federal, state
and local laws.
With the Federal Worker's Adjustment
and retraining notification
Act, also known
as the Warren Act, that
generally requires businesses
with 100 or more employees
to provide 60 days notice
before engaging in mass layoffs.
Warren defines layoffs
as those affecting at
least 500 employees
during a 30 day period.
Though employers can
provide workers with 60 days
of severance pay in lieu of
giving notice and terminated
California employees
have already filed suit
under the Warren Act in
comparable state laws.
Although Musk has several
defenses to their claims,
he claims that he offered
to pay some employees
through January 4th, 2023
which could constitute
compliance with a 60 day rule.
Some employees were
offered severance package
but we don't know enough of
the details yet to determine
whether the packages
complied with the law.
And Musk can also say
that the employees were fired for cause
which was his defense in a
similar lawsuit against Tesla.
When ex Tesla employees sued
Musk under the Warren Act,
he argued that they were all
fired for poor performance
and were not layoffs
requiring advanced notice.
And Musk is also taking
a hard line approach
to remote workers.
He sent a 2:34 AM email
informing the entire workforce
that they needed to work in the office
for at least 40 hours a week
unless they're given
approval to work elsewhere.
And Musk said that he would
personally approve all work
from home requests.
"Obviously, if you are
physically unable to travel
to an office or have a
critical personal obligation
then your absence is understandable."
Now, Musk has the right to
require employees to work
in the office if it
doesn't violate other laws.
He'll have to
exercise this discretion
without running a foul
of the Americans with Disabilities Act
and other laws prohibiting discrimination
against people with disabilities.
He'll also have to follow the FMLA
and other laws that protect an
employee's right to take time
off if they're sick or caring
for an ill family member.
Now, generally, companies
of these sizes have HR
departments to handle these kinds
of requests and obligations,
but sure, Elon is
going to personally make
all of these determinations.
I'm sure that's gonna work out fine.
So where does this leave Twitter?
Well, maybe bankruptcy, even
Elon has explicitly stated
that bankruptcy is on the table
which is not something that you wanna hear
from a new owner just
weeks into their tenure.
By most accounts, Elon paid too much
for Twitter and saddled
it with too much debt.
It's possible that Twitter
shuts down, but it's more likely
that it would just go into bankruptcy
and the debtors would
take a massive haircut
or you can threaten
bankruptcy to force debtors to
take a haircut without
formally going into bankruptcy.
And there are reports
that the banks are currently
marketing their debt
to others and have received offers
of 60 cents on the dollar, though it seems
that they want at least
70 cents on the dollar.
Others have speculated
that Twitter might only be
worth $8 billion at this point
meaning that Elon and his
fellow financiers would lose 80%
of their investments. But I
guess it could have been worse.
They could have purchased FTX.
But now that
Twitter has fired all
the people responsible
for making the site safe
you can never be too careful online.
And that's where today's
sponsored Nord VPN can help
because you know
that incognito mode isn't
actually incognito, right?
And Nord VPN is more than just a VPN.
It comes with a whole suite
of threat protection tools.
For example, if you follow some
of your favorite creators on social media
you might have heard the stories
of channels getting hacked.
Basically, a creator loses access
after a successful attack
or a leaked password.
And in fact, Alex's
Corner, one of our Nebula
friends recently got their
YouTube channel stolen
and turned into a repository
for cryptocurrency scam videos.
But Nord VPN's
Threat protection includes
specific features to warn you
about phishing links as well
as features like a blocker
for malicious ads and
dark web monitoring to see
if your passwords have been leaked.
And of course, Nord VPN is a great VPN.
With Nord, you can surf
the web anonymously
and your location stays private.
It allows me to set my
location all over the world
which lets me access different versions
of my favorite websites.
And when I'm out of the
country and try to connect
to Gmail or a bunch of other
things that I'm logged into
all those accounts usually would freak
out and tell me that I'm being hacked.
So now I just reroute my connection
to the US and my Gmail and
everything is perfectly happy.
So if you'd like to give Nord VPN a try
click on the link that's
on screen right now
or in the description
to get a two year plan
with a huge discount plus
four additional months free
and it's completely risk free
with Nord's 30 day money back guarantee.
So click on the link below
to get a two year plan
with four additional months for free
with a risk free 30 day
money back guarantee as well.
And after that, click
on this box over here
for more Legal Eagle, or
I'll see you in court.